modern popular culture has a fascination
with ninjas they are prominently
featured in video games comic books
movies and novels many characters that
we consider modern like Batman in
particular are heavily inspired by
stories of ninjas and yet all this might
be based on a fantasy the ninja were
likely not what you imagined them to be
they did not wear all black ninjutsu or
shinobi no jutsu is not a fighting style
and they were not the sworn enemy of the
samurai as hard as I looked I couldn't
find any secret ninja training method
for jumping higher in fact they probably
weren't even called ninjas until
recently with shinobi being the more
accurate pronunciation of the kanji but
before you get too disheartened and
dismissed the whole notion of ninjas
being awesome keep in mind that reality
was in some ways even cooler who were
the ninjas really ninjas actually had a
lot more in common with modern CIA or
mi6 agents what makes them even cooler
though is that unlike those agents they
would also be required to engage with
the enemy from time to time essentially
combining the roles of the intelligence
officers with that of Special Ops they
would infiltrate enemy castles collect
information and potentially leave a
trail of chaos and destruction in their
wake all without being noticed a shinobi
was actually a classification of samurai
warrior who would be tasked with
espionage guerrilla warfare arson and
assassination missions and would utilize
stealth disguise and a range of tools in
order to complete those jobs so the
shinobi were not the enemies of the
samurai anymore than SpecOps are the
enemy of army infantry there were simply
different roles within funeral Japan's
military force between the 15th and 17th
centuries many of the principles and
ideas driving the use of ninjas were
imported from the Chinese military
strategist Sam Tsui author of art of war
this seminal text on asymmetric warfare
emphasizes the importance of terrain
timing and strategy in conflict and it's
still incredibly relevant today by
taking strategic advantage of the land
the element of surprise and most
importantly deception
a small army can take on a much larger
one likewise by using a few stealthy
batik ninjas will be possible to thwart
the efforts of a much larger army
through surprise attacks and guerrilla
warfare
they're unemployed to this end by the
feudal lords daimyo of their era if you
needed someone to scope out an enemy
encampment for entry points you would
send a ninja if you needed some to break
into a castle in the dead of night to
kidnap a military generals daughter you
would send a ninja
there isn't a ninja fighting style then
because this training was supplementary
to basic stamina training shinobi no
jutsu was a series of strategies
concepts and instructions to aid with
espionage and deception the fighting
style they did use would likely have
been kenjutsu similar to modern kendo
it's also a myth that ninjas would have
used straight swords instead they likely
use the same curved katanas as any other
samurai ninja training what we know so
what extra training did hinges engaging
the driving principle behind ninjutsu is
deception it has been said that all
combat is really deception and in Dukes
who simply takes this to its natural
extreme what we know of the
supplementary training comes from three
ancient ninja Scrolls the Shonan key the
nimpah den and the balanced and shook I
apologies for my awful pronunciation
these have since been translated into
English and can be bought and read by
anyone these texts deal almost
exclusively with the use of tools herbal
concoctions psychological warfare
explosives disguise and stealth again
there's nothing of a physical regimen
described nor other any combat
techniques like regular samurai ninjas
would have been born into their
professions with the tradition and
fighting styles being passed down from
generation to generation predominantly
in the eager and koga regions other than
the scrolls information on real ninja
training comes from individuals who
claimed a direct family or teaching
lineage tracing back to the ninjas of
old there are recently four individuals
who have made such claims the late
psycho Perdita
who claimed to be the fourteenth master
of the Koga school
Tasha suger Takamatsu Masaaki Hatsumi
and genichi kau akame none of their
statements have been proven however
though this is not to say that they
cannot be true verification of sources
on the jutsu then is extremely difficult
and has led to many heated debates
however several themes and concepts do
occur repeatedly across all sources
making it likely that they are
to some more accurate espionage and
stealth the image of the black-clad
ninja crawling across rooftops is only
partially true it's true for instance
that ninjas would have scaled buildings
in this manner in fact they even would
have carried folding bamboo or rope
ladders at times for crossing between
rooftops
they may also abuse samurai sword as a
stepper when scaling walls propping them
against the wall and then stepping on
the tsuba or handguard should someone
catch a glimpse of a ninja spy they
would scatter items on the other side of
the building as a distraction ways to
mask sounds actually take up a fair
chunk of the ninja Scrolls
once inside ninjas were taught to move
close to the walls where the floorboards
released slightly to creak hugging walls
also allow them to reduce their visible
silhouette to minimize noise they would
breathe through their mouths and
reportedly sometimes insert a small
piece of paper to further dampen the
sound of their breath ninjas also loves
to move silently
the number of specific movement patterns
were taught to enable this including a
controversial one that may have involved
stepping on their own hands clothing
where reality probably differed from the
myth however is in the garb there's no
evidence that ninjas wore masks though
it's not outside the realms of
possibility likewise there's no
historical record of ninjas wearing
all-black
it has been suggested in fact that
ninjas may have been more likely to wear
dark blue so as to more closely blend
into the night sky however they would
have far more often worn civilian
clothes in order to move among crowds
unnoticed a particularly popular ploy
was to dress as a homeless person so as
to move particularly unnoticed and to
minimize interactions they would even
practice limping and moving so as to
appear feeble lowering others
estimations of their abilities in other
instances they may have worn large hats
to disguise their identity or dress as
farmers the latter allowed them to carry
tools that could be useful for
self-defence without arousing suspicion
the ban sin-shoo Chi includes numerous
tips of strategies for those interested
in mastering the art of disguise
explaining how small details like a
pebble in the shoe can alter gait to go
a long way towards obscuring identity
the same techniques are used by the CIA
to help agents disappear in the field
even switching identities on the move
without drawing attention to themselves
tools
[Music]
she maybe carried a wide range of
different tools at different times in
order to get the upper hand on their
opponents we've already discussed the
use of bamboo ladders for instance one
of my favorite examples as their use of
pointed tax called caltrops which they
would scatter behind themselves whilst
fleeing pursuers would then step on
these and injure their feet when
infiltrating an enemy base or castle
ninjas would scatter these caltrops
around the exit points keeping note of
their exact locations this way when
discovered they could escape and take
out large numbers of the opposition
similarly they have been known to pull
down wooden bridges and set fire to
access points this is the perfect
example of how a single stealthy ninja
can take on a far greater force through
sheer cunning as seen in much friction
grappling hooks were also used commonly
by ninjas these were not only used for
scaling walls but also for the
aforementioned pulling down of bridges
they would also use a thick sack in
order to push themselves through
brambles and bushes likewise they used a
short tool called the kunai for digging
their way under fences one of the
simplest tools that many shinobi would
carry was a rope this had countless uses
including lifting other heavy tools
after scaling a wall ninjas were adept
at crafting explosions poisons adhesives
and more from their surrounding fauna
they even had ingredients for energy
snacks that could sustain them for hours
on end psychological warfare a large
part of ninjutsu was learning how to
understand to manipulate people many of
the soft skills discussed in my video on
mi6 training would apply here their job
would often involve reconnaissance and
extracting information meaning they
needed to know how to get people to talk
and how to identify potential informants
one piece of advice possibly from ninja
legend hattori hanzo was to approach
formerly important individuals who had
since fallen out of favour such people
are more likely to be candid with gossip
while also being in a position to know a
lot of sensitive information likewise a
ninja must learn to gain the trust of
people from all classes and ways of life
to adapt their demeanor and behavior to
fit in playing dumb is also a strategy
that's often recommended for ninjas
feigning ignorance increases the
likelihood that others will tell you
things in confidence
as you appear to pose no threat this
requires the ninja to completely abandon
their ego in service of their mission
overcoming social pressures is an
incredibly useful tool and one that I've
talked about in the past with regards to
CBT and soft skills physical training
unfortunately we know very little of the
physical training regimen of the ninjas
or the hand-to-hand combat
as mentioned ninjas would have likely
received the same training as samurai
with additional skills being taught on
top all emphasis would primarily have
been on armed combat including archery
in the use of other tools samurai would
also have learned a number of empty hand
techniques and likely jiu-jitsu from
which Aikido judo and some forms of
karate such as water Rio are derived we
can also make some assumptions about the
type of physical training that would
have been logical ninjas to engage in
ninjas required a certain degree of
athleticism for rope climbing men are
also known to climb high into trees in
order to hide and/or use as a lookout
climbing and body weight training then
would seemingly be sensible options some
aforementioned last ninjas do also claim
to have some insider knowledge regarding
the types of physical training that
ninjas might have engaged in say ku
Fujita for instance describes ninjas as
doing a lot of hiking being able to walk
350 miles between Edo Tokyo and Osaka in
just three days Vegeta also describes
wooden sandals that were designed
specifically to train leg strength and
balance he says that the ninjas did
indeed trained specifically for jumping
and that they were able to jump up to
seven feet in the air high enough to
leap straight over an opponent assuming
this is a vertical jump this would be to
put higher than what is believed to be
the world record held by kudos eonni
they're not officially verified it is
more than likely then that such claims
are hyperbolic or exaggerated but it's
also true that some form of foot or jump
training would likely have been involved
more uncredited sources describe ninjas
as jumping out of an Ava holes that they
dug for practice and using weighted
vests when jumping they might also
apparently have used calf jumps jumping
using only their feet whilst keeping
their legs entirely straight cow akane
similarly describes walking on the sides
of the feet to strengthen them he also
talks about hardening the body through
conditioning so while we can't know for
sure is possible that ninjas might
supplemented their martial arts training
in an shinobi no jujitsu training with
bodyweight training plyometrics jump
training body hardening climbing and
long-distance cardio mental training
surprisingly included in the scrolls is
guidance for daily work suggesting that
ninja may have been more than
mercenaries these segments also teach
the martial qualities of mundane tasks
mr. Miyagi style in short everything can
be training khufu lifting everything we
do is I'll do it he lives in how we put
on a jacket
I would pick after jacket and live scene
how we treat people
everything is cooked for ninjas also
learned some interesting mental
strategies to help them on their
missions
these included the use of beans
transferred between two pouches for
counting that is to say that rather than
have to remember how many enemies they
were counting they simply moved two bean
from one bag to the next each time they
spotted another combatant the use of
mnemonics is of course something that
I'm very interested in like many
explorers shinobi knew how to navigate
by looking at the Stars and how to
assess the weather and the moon in order
to time an infiltration when they would
be most concealed ninjas used special
spells and incantations that they
believed could help them on their
missions of course today we probably
assume that these ankle tations would
not be effective that said it's possible
they had some psychological or placebo
effects potentially serving as anchors
or mantras that would help to keep them
calm under pressure and help them to
embody the nature of the animals or
perhaps properties that they were
interested in more fully more useful
today is the practice of developing
attention and sharp reflexes
genichi Kao akame describes a training
methods that would involve listening for
the drop of a pinprick others to have
described a similar technique he and
several other sources describe
meditation whilst watching a candle
flame as well which is actually a common
meditation technique used today there
are those that believe the ninjas were
descendants of the yamabushi mountain
priests who eventually settled in the
Koga and eager regions and began taking
on workers isatis ins and spies the
yamabushi sought superhuman powers
through closeness with nature a CETIS
ism abstinence martial arts and feats of
endurance yamabushi are often pictured
sitting underneath waterfalls which
would help to both hone the senses
endure the elements and toughening the
body whether this was a practice that
ninjas in fact continued is uncertain
likewise it's possible not certain that
ninjas would have used other similar
methods in common with the alibi sheep
what we can learn from ninjas today this
script is currently nearly 3,000 words
long and they only touched lightly on
what we know about ninjas it's a topic
that I'll definitely be exploring more
in the future in the next couple of
weeks I'll be uploading a post at the
bian ear looking at how to take all
these lessons and directly apply them to
modern life you can also find more
information by reading the accompanying
post on the by own ear that goes with
this video
Calico me says the skills of the ninja
are no longer useful today whether
that's entirely true is up for debate
but we can certainly take the principles
of shinobi you know jutsu and apply them
to modern training and modern contexts
what could a ninja do today with a drone
ethical hacking skills parkour and
potential knowledge of biochemistry and
what benefit could a businessperson or a
politician have by learning the social
skills these soft skills and the
manipulation of the ninja combined with
the ability to focus intently stay calm
and move with accuracy speed and
precision you could continue in the
spirit of the ninja and thrive as a
result I hope you found this video
useful interesting guys if you did then
please leave a like please share around
I worked really hard on this one
especially the research and the script
so let me know what you think are there
any skills here that you think would be
relevant to modern life is there
anything interesting about ninjas you
know that I've missed out I'll be doing
many more videos like this in future
I've got to look at the life of Bruce
Lee coming up I'll be discussing
Nightwing training as I've been
promising I'll be doing a video on body
language on ethical hacking potentially
if there's any interested in that so let
me know if that all sounds good
stay tuned thanks a ton for watching and
I'll see you next time bye for now